Eclipse enthusiast sets bill and Sharon
Hawes have spent 26 years traveling all
over the world to see these previous
spectacles the couple have gone from
Chile to Ethiopia to the Arctic Circle
to see eclipses but this year it's
coming right to them the Eclipse will
travel directly over their farm that's
nice Adriana Diaz met this adventurous
couple she's in Carbondale Illinois with
their story Adriana good morning good
morning people from across the country
will soon fill this Stadium in
Carbondale one of the top spots to view
the event totality will also be viewable
in parts of Missouri that's where the
couple we met will be now these aren't
just casual fans of the cosmos these are
Eclipse pros who say this year's event
above all the others will be peak lips
bliss there's just nothing else in the
universe like a total solar eclipse the
during totality the air gets cool you
have a 360-degree dusk and then all the
sudden it's over and until the next time
so it's science and magic all turned
together
Sedgwick Ville Missouri population 197
is about to get an influx of eclipse
Watchers Sharon and Billy Haas are
welcoming about 60 friends and family
members to the family farm which falls
within the path of totality a scientific
serendipity for two Eclipse aficionados
life-changing sounds a little much but
life-changing you would say just a few
seconds or minutes it's where you wake
up in the sky it's not where we can
reach we can't go you know and we can't
rerun the tape the houses have been
chasing the eclipses phenomenon around
the globe since 1991 when they visited
Costa Rica in this day and age when
everyone's looking down and moving
quickly does an eclipse remind you to
slow down I think it reminds you to
appreciate the moment we're live in this
kind of fantastic improbable set of
scientific realities but it really is a
kind of moving experience so it was like
okay let's go do this again but you
can't do it right away you have to wait
a year or two and go to a different
place they've made 14 trips from
Thailand to Easter Island
to Mongolia and Libya we stayed in the
Sahara Desert these are the tents we
stayed in skipping over here this is
Billy painting afterwards and this is me
with my equipment oh they have a routine
Sharon takes about 25 photos to capture
the full moon evolution from the partial
eclipse to the corona to the diamond
ring effect but after discovering that
photographs couldn't fully capture the
deep blue sky they observed with their
eyes well these are two of my paintings
Billy started painting the thing that
changes of course from one Eclipse to
the next is the size and shape of the
corona and the exact flavor of blue that
you got on that particular Eclipse the
Blues have them all their coldest
eclipse was north of the Arctic Circle
in Svalbard Norway two years ago it was
eight degrees below zero when the
Eclipse came and the moon blocked the
Sun it went to 18 degrees below zero
I do water color so you know we should
put the water down and and then when it
came time to do the painting there was
no indoors they document their Eclipse
encounters with storyboards and
memorabilia like this carpet from
Mongolia in their house you almost can't
escape the Sun and moons gaze what are
your favorite eclipses all of them the
journey is the actual experience of the
eclipses and so it's very hard to choose
among them you sound like a mother
describing her children actually that's
what I think of Sofia you don't have a
favorite oh you know I may have a
favorite after Monday we didn't get to
bring you know 60 people although many
of these others that and these are 60
people that we treasure and love so my
aunt and uncle have been chasing these
around the world for years and I've
never seen one so I'm excited to see
what the hype is all about this year
those loved ones will be joining the
houses who've been married for forty
eight and a half years and they'll all
be wearing matching commemorative
t-shirts are you a little disappointed
that you won't be able to travel for
this one no no it's all about family
and the amazing thing having gone around
the world and having told our families
how wonderful this is and showing them
pictures that we will get to show them a
real eclipse and we're all coming
together so instead of you chasing the
Eclipse the Eclipse this time is coming
just about coming to us I like that it
took it a while to get around to it
that's happening though Sharon and Billy
have traveled to 14 eclipses they've
only seen 11 because weather block their
view three times now if the weather
doesn't cooperate today the couple told
us that's okay they're just thrilled to
be with friends and family plus they
have something else to celebrate Grandma
Louise is 90th birthday happy birthday
Louise happy birthday grandma like so
many things in life yeah clip cesare
best shared yeah but what a great couple
though 40 and it's great that they both
feel the same about it absolutely I can
see the bonding thing that he paints she
photographs